why did a random window just pop up when
i was about to do this
i'm having tech they are random women
[Laughter]
and we are live welcome to the last word
fresh on that thursday evening campfire
ibontis thai guy travis just the guys
today i kind of like that i kind of like
that man it's been a while just the
homies at the campfire
just always man how we doing man how you
doing here start with you doing good i
put a pin in eldering i finished it
so i finally did uh
level 161 113 hours
finished it
had pretty much the final stretch to go
and then just made a beeline in one
afternoon straight through most of the
bosses in the finale i was strong i had
a very good sword and just kind of
rolled with it um
actually beat melania to before i went
to the final boss so she was good i
missed
two main bot two optional bosses i think
of the two that i missed that they told
me and a couple and i think two side
quests i'll say i did like 85 percent of
the game which i don't feel too bad
about if you know
mostly pretty natural exploring and
a couple things are a little crazy but
overall happy to finish that one now
i've got quite a few indies that i want
to work through and
you know there's definitely some fun
stuff tunic have a nice death
um a couple others i know um like rogue
legacy too i kind of want to try that
one stanley parable i've never played
before so there's definitely some stuff
that i want to experience
and now is that good window of got a new
season at st knock that stuff out and
then we got summer's downtime because
there's not a whole lot going on this
summer
there's going to be announcements but
there's not going to be a whole lot of
games coming out so that's kind of true
real quick i did see you tweet in
reference to elder ring
where is it in the great pantheon of
souls games and overall for your game of
the year so far
haven't played horizon yet and as i
played horizon one at the start of the
year i'm spacing them just so it's not
like
100 hours of horizon so fair i need some
separation from it
right now it's top easy because i
haven't played that many different
things seafood was cool this i mean it
doesn't hold a candle obviously to alden
ring um
it's
as for the souls rankings in the series
until bloodborne is highly renowned by a
lot of people
but until that game gets the 60 frames
per second patch
i'm not gonna go back and play it so i'm
not gonna get a vote on it so until it
gets to be 60 frames i'm not gonna go
play it again because i had a good
experience that was my very first one
um
and it's what kicked me down the soul's
path and i like i'm glad it was there i
want to go back and play it when it's
like 4k 60 on ps5 until then
it was it was cool like for me sekiro
was very special because that's one of
the hardest boss fights i've ever had i
remember and it's so much
more you can't really over level so much
it is a lot of skill in that one you do
get some abilities that help you adapt
but you get one sword there's not like
over leveling in things um but also i
mean there's moments in eldering like
the tree sentinel was my white whale for
a little while that opening guy that you
you know the big gold horse guy
uh he was my white whale for like a good
while and then finally i got to a point
where i stomped him but
i don't know it's like dark souls 3
because i replayed dark souls remastered
played demon souls demon souls on ps5 is
beautiful but it's got some quality of
life stuff you can see they learned from
dark souls 3 was a really good step
after bloodborne to be like okay got 60
frames per second felt really good kind
of kept some of the
faster motion that they've stuck with
which i appreciate
um
seguro is just special for me because of
the final boss in sakhiro that fight was
five to six hours to probably combined
over a couple of streams that i finally
beat him and that was like one of the
hardest like combinations of things to
put together
um so i don't know between those two
because there are moments in elden ring
when i'm just like damn the vistas the
moments where things flip upside down if
you guys know what i'm talking about
there are like the first time you're in
stormvale castle
they're both really i don't i honestly
don't know right now i haven't played
sakura in so long elden rings so fresh
but eldering has got to be close to
probably a number two i would say
um sekhiro
it could be easily be number one
probably then securo
uh i haven't played bloodborne again if
bloodborne gets a 4k60 patch then i'll
go talk about a re-rank but for me eldon
ring securo probably duking it out i
think just because of my experiences
with both of those were very very
special
that's where i'm at
travis what even i saw your review i
know what you were finally waiting to uh
release that one
yeah weirdly that i played that game
like over a month ago and so it feels
like i didn't even review it you know
like the embargo was so ahead on that
one that i'm just like oh yeah that game
that i
feel like i barely remember i feel like
i played the game last year um but yeah
that my review went live today i think
the game is out tomorrow or maybe even
tonight at 9 00 pm pacific so yeah um
yeah that that uh
super fun it's on game pass so if you
have that you should definitely give it
a try it's it's like a four to five hour
game uh so you can burn through it
pretty quick and it's got a great story
fantastic visual style read my review or
or watch the video it's i i kind of see
everything i want to say in that one but
um yeah i had a ton of fun with that
game
um and then aside from that i'm
my destiny raid guide
that is way too late uh is is gonna be
uh
uh live uh fairly shortly on ign um i'm
doing some previews on some stuff i
can't talk about
and uh
my next review is
uh the evil dead game
uh that multiplayer you know you guys
know evil dead right ash williams chain
sub boy uh yeah they're uh
i think you might be muted sorry i'm
beautiful yeah yeah yeah the classic i
know what you mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah so they're they they're
making a video game and i'm going to be
reviewing that probably over this
weekend so
keep it busy man i'm i'm you know i'm
doing me also helped ign decide the 25
best pc games
uh today we had a
meeting we've been narrowing it down
from like 500 games to
2 on the 25s of that list still
no so
the list is
top top 25 pc games to play right now
and
the context there is that we cut any
game that's 10 years old or or older off
of the list
so it's it's like recent games and
recent ish you know it's got to be in
the last 10 years and uh they have to
have some like relevancy on the pc
platform like some life to them like
things you should play
now we recommend so be curious yeah we
we just decided on our on our final 25
in the order i fought very hard for a
game that became number one on the list
so
i think if you heard me if you heard me
talk about uh unique pc experiences you
probably can guess ah yeah i'll let the
i'll let the uh
i'll let the article speak for itself oh
yeah
nice nice nice chicago
yes ben um i've been down with the beta
squad so i've been playing this game
called lost eidolons
and um it's i'm you know i'm lord
turn-based i love turn-based games it
spoke to me
based on the look and and the setting so
it's kind of like
fire emblem and banana saga had a baby
and then tried to be like super
narrative jrpg
and there's parts of this game where
it's absolutely stunning and then it's
other parts of it where i'm like
man i see like i got this kickstarter
this is budget this is just
the frames and the jake and i'm like oh
and it could be special so i'm really
rooting for it
but um yeah like it's just this thing
that they do with storytelling like
in-game storytelling is fine like on the
battle story sounds fine but outside of
it it's just a little rough so we're
playing that i've been doing a little
mlb the show i've been raiding a lot
with val we took tasks through the um
the uh for vowel for the first time so
it was interesting taking someone
through valve for the first time and we
didn't do too bad obviously we got to um
relic was a little bit of pain point but
not as bad as i thought it was it was
more so just the speed of getting the
glyph clippers out and people making
their sign calls and stuff like that
surprisingly roke was
was the issue
just getting people to do the right
thing and transfer the buff and you know
dps and stuff like that so
we cleaned it up at the end we got it we
got him his first clear so i've been
doing that
and um yeah i know we got a lot of stuff
to talk about with the 12 but other than
that yeah it's been there i've been
ready i'm going to do uh yomi which uh
trav was talking about i'm going to get
ready probably try to touch that tonight
and uh yeah i'm just going to blow
through that and like you can do that in
like a sitting yeah
six hours yeah ish
kind of starts with the most honestly so
yeah i i kind of get excited when i hear
like ted howard other games i'm like oh
okay
yeah and i'm going back to seafood i
know i i got to get that done i was i
slacked got caught up with death i was
going to say because there's a deluxe
edition man who hyped it up so much i
was like
you didn't get that too bro when destiny
hit it was always for me it was that was
it i was in the mix but no i saw they
dropped some new content some new suits
and some stuff so i'm like yeah i gotta
get back so
this week the plan is yomi
and sifu kind of get that done while we
got this little break before the new
season i'm really excited about all the
new season stuff coming sandbox-wise
put this little psa in here for you guys
i know we typically just covered destiny
on here but bungie did put a statement
out with regards to the draft on the roe
v wade type stuff so we do talk about
this here if you do want to skip ahead
um just skip ahead about 11 minutes in
the podcast and you will get back to the
destiny stuff but if you want to listen
to our discussion about it here we go
nice well should we broach the fun one
let's do it
all right
well as some of you guys have been
paying attention to and if we lose some
of you on this part of the podcast
that's fine
um
first thing we got to talk about is the
giant elephant in the world and we can't
not talk about it because if we don't
talk about things that happen in the
world can't really live in the bubble of
video games all the time which is kind
of why i appreciated the things that
happened on twitter from bungie
uh i'm getting a weird echo right now
yeah i'm coming through you yeah
yep i was getting my voice through your
mic
so i'm gonna read this one from bungie
because they actually supported it
specifically but they put out a post so
i'm gonna read their words and then
we'll talk about it
at bungie we believe that everyone has a
right to choose their own path and that
freedom is expressed across all facets
of life the leaked draft decision by the
u.s supreme court to overturn roe versus
wade represents a blow to freedom in
america as a direct attack on human
rights by creating a divide between
those who possess the fundamental right
to make health care decisions that are
right for them and those who do not
possess that same freedom this decision
should it become final
will have far-reaching consequences that
will be felt for generations across
socio-economic lines bungie is committed
to safeguarding the freedom and privacy
of its employees and providing support
to all employees affected by this
decision standing up for reproductive
choice and liberty is not a difficult
decision to make and bungie remains
dedicated to upholding these values if
you'd like to donate to organizations
that support rights to healthcare there
are a few different links that they put
down below so if you want to check any
of those out as places to support
basically all this is talking about uh
the leaked draft which
uh supposedly is going to overturn and
basically make rowan v wade for however
old it is
null and void 50 years but i thought it
was about 50 years
yeah
so normally i know we don't talk about
this type of stuff on the podcast we
will get to the destiny stuff um i will
try and get an idea of a time stamp but
too big of a topic
half of the population is going to be
affected by this and honestly the whole
population so i wanted to get you guys
takes on it um thoughts on this one
whoever wants to start
it's not an easy one to start on not
jumping i mean listen you know how i
feel generally i tend to not jump into
political stuff as a separator but we
got to talk about it at the end of the
day you know this is bungie taking a
stand historically they have been very
vocal and using their platform using
their company to show their position on
stuff as far as black lives matter lgbtq
issues you know this doesn't surprise me
what i will give them
credit for
that bungie twitter account was lit i
don't know that's sort of clapbacks
absolutely when people were like yo shut
up stick to video games what and they yo
they were going in like they were not
backing down
and salute to them you know they choose
to use their platform how they choose
you know for me
it's again a side that i'm on so i'll
just be brutally honest in that sense so
it doesn't really affect me in that way
but i will say this
when you make stances like that right
corporate wise generally people tell
corporate to shy away from that kind of
stuff because it's technically not good
for business so there is quote unquote
risk so to speak by alienating a side
that may not agree with your stance but
hey this is how they want to run their
company this is what they want to do and
kudos to them for how they choose to do
it so it is what it is is where i'm at
with it
trav
yeah people who know me will know that i
very much enjoy political talk so
i'm the opposite here but i have a whole
lot i can say on this topic that i think
would probably
be
not very called for on this podcast but
i will just say
that
whether you like it or not companies
nowadays the new model is that they do
make political statements and i i guess
the
the elephant in the room there is that
uh companies have always been political
it's just that they made donations in
the uh the background some companies
still do that
um but now i think uh millennials in
particular have sort of pushed the
corporate world to like stand up for
things and to have political views and
so whether or not you like it uh
that is sort of um the model now people
want to believe in the company in
addition to the products and i think uh
it's cool to see
bungie using their influence to
to advocate for the things that they
believe in and even if you don't agree
with those i think uh it's important
that the people who work at that company
feel like their voice and their values
are represented at a corporate level
and so
um yeah at the
to all avoid getting into the topic
itself and how messed up i personally
feel the situation is but i'll just say
that uh i'm glad bungie is is stating
their viewpoint and i think uh more
companies should do that uh
if they uh
if if they feel they're reflecting the
values of their their uh
what's called a constituency but really
it's their employees right but uh i
think more often than not they probably
don't do that but it's cool to see
bungie doing that and doing so publicly
and with the backing of of their
employees it seems like so it's cool
stuff
yeah
i mean i'm in the same place you guys
are it's like i'm in the same boat i
mean on the same side of the issue
because obviously i think you know the
fact that this could potentially be
overturned is absolute crap um if you've
looked into as to why and all of that
stuff people are going to be on
different sides of it but it was as you
said
um whoever was on bungie's twitter that
day had free reign to do whatever they
wanted
in like a pc way and just the roasting
stuff they're like you are a video game
company was the reply to their post and
they replied you are a toaster bro like
some of the roasts were
really really good um
and it was just some of the things where
people like you just you need to stay
like it's always the whole stay in your
lane but as travis basically stated is
so many companies don't stay in their
lane they just typically don't talk
about it in a forward way so many
companies make donations to this or that
or support these things then finally
when you know there's some investigation
comes out be like oh this company
donated to this thing then the backlash
comes in bungie's brave enough to just
stand there and be like this is what we
believe in as a company and we stand for
this as a company from leadership down
now maybe not everybody in the company
may have the exact same values
but in general they're trying to
basically go
in the support of you know the choice of
healthcare that's the you know
fundamental fundamental right to make
health care care decisions that are
right for them and that's what they're
doing for their employees as well and
the tough thing now i know for bungie
especially is some of their remote
positions are in the state i live in
texas which is a really really messed up
state right now for multiple reasons and
i live here and it's just watching some
of the news sometimes is just a mess for
all of the politics in this state much
less what's going on in the rest of the
country so
i am happy to see that they took a stand
to say this is what we believe in these
are the things that we support and
honestly i'm happy they did and it's one
of those reasons where you know people
may give bungie a hard time for a
magnitude of reasons we've given them a
hard time when they don't get stuff
right but in my mind it's nice to see
and one person have followed on twitter
or that i saw on twitter is basically
saying they're the only video game
company to say anything
and so
i was like in sony as you know the
acquisition's not done but i was like i
mean they're
they're working on it it's like sony
didn't just say like hey don't say it
right
like they they know what they got into
so yeah
it's one of those things for me it's
like bungie's gonna do what they're
gonna do and it's nice to see that
they're still capable of saying what
they want to as well and this is proof
like if sony had any issue of them
saying this or otherwise
or if they get a say in it you can see
that bungie's still going to
act exactly as they did before which is
nice to see that they have the freedom
of choice
of saying what they want to when they
want to yeah they've been consistently
opinionated and they stand on their
square and i think that's the identity
they've formed over the years and it's
consistent with that so i was i wasn't
surprised and um yeah you know it's it
goes to show you that like you said the
saudi acquisition didn't change anything
which a lot of people may have wanted
wanted to see if they would kind of like
be quiet more so to speak but not the
case yeah necromancers all said it well
and i think travis would agree with this
too because i know he's one who enjoys
it is
what was
commenting yeah he's like what's been
lost in current politics is the debate
in positions and ideas it's full of
absolutionists there is no
middle ground there's no discussion
there's no nuance there is no having a
discussion about topics
hey
let me know why you're coming from your
side and it's just this like angry yell
of i will only do this one thing
there's no discussion there's no
middle ground there's no compromise it's
like my way or the highway
a lot of it on either side of the road
as well
and it's just really sad to see that we
can't have a discussion anymore it's
just like there is no
halfway in between let's do some of this
stuff and the other side and it's just
one of those things and the other thing
i got to say on the topic too is i sent
the clip to these guys but i've been a
fan of george carlin for as long as i
can remember
somehow i got to watch him when i was
young enough that i probably shouldn't
have been able to watch him because his
language was always hilarious
but
um there is like if you ever want to
know my thoughts on the whole matter go
look up the opening of george carlin
back in town but the first 10 minutes
covers everything but that's 25 years
ago and not a whole lot has changed and
it's just a hilarious special but i've
always enjoyed his comedy and it's
he was spot on 25 years ago and it seems
like nothing has changed and it's really
really really sad
yeah man
it's the real
anything else you guys want to add
not much for me unless you try i've got
anything it's going to be it's going to
be a fun
comment
comment section that too a couple of
years i mean it's just lots of stuff
coming to the foreground so yeah you
guys should vote i would like to just
say here yeah please vote
if you own it but yeah just vote that's
all i gotta say just go find a way to
vote in every election midterms matter
yes people don't yeah yeah
vote local you know
that's my favorite actually yeah yeah
that's my psa as a as a guy who likes to
be politically active i don't talk about
it a lot in the game sphere but like
y'all should y'all should vote it
doesn't take that long yeah
an hour a week maybe you know if that to
stay informed and that sort of thing so
that's real
i love you guys
love you too bro
this has been three dudes talk about
women's reproductive rights
this going to be a very short running
segment but all i can say is
yeah of all the people on this podcast
and everybody who is like the people of
us on the podcast as in males we should
not be making decisions for the other
sex so
that's one of the easiest ways to phrase
it um
so yeah i had to get out of the way
that's like right at about 23 minutes in
so i will try and remember that one just
for a little yeah
cut point
um
and now we'll get into the destiny stuff
so i'll probably cut a little bit in
there those of you guys want to watch it
thank you those of you guys who prefer
to skip it that's up to you
but as for destiny stuff since we do not
have a guest uh we can just kind of jump
straight into things and starting
warlocks
the picture was on the twab and the
warlocks are winning how much have you
signed they were signed to win this year
yeah they they for the titans got the
first one so zavala could you know do
his thing up on the tower and then
hunters they had to give him give him
something because you know they lost
they have no vanguard yeah they have no
vanguard so they had to give him
something and then now
and then now the last you know finally
pulling up the rear like you know steve
rogers running in the back but you know
they're going to because
because it's icora's season they have to
give it to them oh that's that's how
we're actually that's what we're doing
that's how we rationalize so i'll try to
see how the titans are processing
i mean we we've had that medal for like
two years so it's like well
we can we can let you have one of them
so it's fine
just like you know when i come into the
town
that warlock flag is raised full mast
it's glorious this just glory you see
that bird just
hawking over everyone
you must not be used to seeing the
warlock symbol above anything because
you can't pop so much huh like you it
must be a totally new sensation
nice man tower's nice i see people
dances like there's a party in the
streets
[Laughter]
some of those emails look like they
could do that too
but yeah it's been fun man oh my god
look at that here goes the tight belly
they're gonna bring it for more like me
it's like cognitive
i will say this though i will say this
in fairness
okay can you admit that it's a little
suspicious that every every year it's
like uh uh just like an easy win for one
class that's kind of weird i feel like
one way or the other like yeah i feel
the community i've seen community heads
say yo i'm being a warlock this year or
yo i'm going to do that like we got to
do it for the locks bro
i've seen guys do so i'm not even gonna
lie and say i have it but i do feel like
like some of the community leaders get
together and say what they're gonna do
and then some people follow so it's time
man it's time you know we we need a belt
too i want that that tanker whatever
that that thing y'all showed me i need
that you need two platinum torches lit
which you could literally do probably
friday tomorrow if you get a platinum
score in there and then you can
literally buy it this weekend
i gotta say is
yeah i need you to get that it fits you
way too well like it just it is you but
also like if i'm up here i'm just like
hold on let me consume from my
giant tanker i won't point you in the
basement
yeah it's like it looks so
somebody in chat said it through there
like it looks so over the top and
ridiculous i kind of like it like it's
so much
it's so like gaudiness that i kind of
i'm okay with it it's weird normally i
wouldn't be attracted that i'm like
or just look
i like i'm debating i'm still not
entirely sure yeah i can't you you're
very subtle you're very resilient that's
what i'm saying it's so not me but i
think it's so far beyond it may have
come all the way back around to be like
this might be cool like or just he's
tanker curious
tanker curious
definitely a pimp cup listen man come
with the opponent get your callus song
be get fat from strength
you can you can say you're not into
gaudy things but let's be honest if that
if that cup if you drank from that cup
in uh
in the uh
the the last crusade indiana jones movie
you for sure
you chose poorly
poorly for sure yeah yeah that that is
100 that cup
for sure yeah yeah that is that is so
yeah it is cool i will not be buying it
i don't need more junk in my house for
sure yeah i have a lot of junk and
that's what i was like it doesn't make
much sense but it is cool and i will say
while the outside is not washable like
the inside is just this like insert and
just throw it in the washer and the
dishwasher you're good to go so like the
cleaning on it's easy means like the
outside should be maintained so that
actually helps as opposed to something
that's just going to like melt in the
dishwasher so that's it definitely
that's a good thing um outside of the
rewards there's a mid-out there's like a
metal which you can probably like wear
around your neck that i'm not doing
because that's about as much as the cup
and i just can't do that one that being
said
uh this is a convoluted and kind of
buggy kickoff to this whole event
so there is multiple
things that you need to try and do some
are active now some are active later
there's practice there's recreation
there i'm sorry there's training there's
recreation there's competitor this is
how much uh you've got two different
sides of invisible platforms that
eventually light up and then on top of
that you've got the whole thing that
people are going for that wasn't
dropping for about the first 24 hours
uh so to start the title which is one of
the reasons most people are doing this
besides if you don't have the exotic
machine gun
get it please it is one of the easiest
quests to do it's just only around for
three weeks a year but it is
three
weeks
and then theoretically you've never had
a better season for a machine gun exotic
coming up because the 40 buff and the 20
against bosses it gets both of those
it's got a shield
you can't ask for a better time to get
the machine gun it is so easy to get
then the catalyst is not bad either if
you play this thing enough so
please get air apparent if you don't
have it it's not hard to do
the submachine gun the title is
interesting it's got the perk class
classy contender which is going to give
you class energy uh i thought uh cool
guy had a little review on it i saw and
um nothing about it really stands
stands out as like god tier
but i mean new rad wasn't really feeling
it and then he got a chance to play with
it he was like you know kind of actually
feels good cool guys it's like it's got
the
it's a weird thing most aggressives
aren't very stable and they don't feel
that good generally but this one from
what i'm gathering from a couple
different people who i would typically
see not it actually might be worth your
time like stats for all one for all for
pve probably an easy one to go for
because those two can synergize really
well just hit three targets and then
have fun for a bit um pvp it's still
gonna have decency you know smgs are
gonna be a bit more of a thing with
sidearms and stuff coming in
because shotguns and fusions are being
pulled back a bit for range so those are
gonna be a little less viable um
also scavenger pvpmo we'll get to that
type of stuff but i wanted to see
first off i know i just talked for a lot
there and covered a lot how was your
guys opening interaction were you guys
confused how's it all been we'll go
through how all the quests and stuff
work but how just you go into guardian
games too much too little just a mess
what do you guys think
what do you got trav
uh i just thought it was kind of boring
was my initial thought like you know you
get in and there's like all this
pageantry about guardian games and then
they're like all right what am i going
to be doing send me off to play and like
the first day i think they just said
like
go do something
they didn't even really give you
direction they're just like go do
something
laurels and i was like
okay i'll go do something bungee and i
just kind of looked around at all the
stuff i played 100 times and i was like
all right let's go find something to do
and then i came back and they're like
all right now do some strikes and i'm
like
some strides your favorite i i ended up
playing gambit
wow
just out of like spite of strikes or
what yeah it was it was it was it was
the thing that day that you know the
focus that was yesterday yeah it was the
low focus and i was just like all right
play some gambit and i ended up playing
that i actually liked that more than
strikes which i guess i've just played
strikes too many times because like
those just do nothing for me now
um but
yeah i just it's a lot it's the thing i
keep saying i don't like about destiny
which is when you point me to all the
old stuff and you go do it but this time
do it because we
say so
damn
again so i don't know just kind of
boring um i
would prefer if they came up with some
uniqueness to it that said i haven't
done a lot with the
competitive strike thing yet which
is kind of you know it's not much but
it's at least something the strike
scoring and so i played the strike uh
i said i i played the strike uh scoring
and i didn't do super well but i was
with a match matchmade team but i could
see how if you were playing with some
some sweat lords and you ran through and
just killed everything and did really
well how that could be fun so maybe i'll
give that a try but yeah my initial
thought at least this week is i've just
been kind of doing it casually and
thinking to myself like yeah this is
kind of boring
i don't feel like a champion doing this
i feel like i feel like a guy who's
wasting his time especially when you're
when you're when you see the warlock
flag up high and you're just like i'm
not gonna be able to change that it's
like you know
these few things that i deposit aren't
going to do anything discouraged
what is it what does my vote matter
now you don't want to vote
that jumped in it's you know it's it's
cardio games it's i mean i like the the
the the way it looked and they had the
little platform thingies and in the
center and i'm like all right you know
we get today i will say i feel it's like
convoluted like just don't i don't know
it just didn't seem very straightforward
as like past ones you know kind of thing
so i got my little warlock bond which i
was like that's cute little warlock
blonde cute little fire going we'll say
each of the class items are probably
more ornate with like yes more metals
more colorings more
like it's almost again that's like the
whole theme of like the tanker we were
talking about they're
so much more like literally decorated
like metal decorated than
ever before because like the titan
class item is sitting down there looks
like you've been through
50 years of military service with all
the metals on there and then the hunter
one as well is just about as much i know
the warlocks probably minor over there
on the arm but both of those they're
really
way over the top for decoration they
don't look bad actually shaded one
purple gonna go with my purple theme i
got going right now it wasn't too shabby
but yeah they are
you get you're like okay so i picked up
my class item now what yeah it was one
of them things and then a funny story my
i'm stupid i'm thinking that the
medallion case
you have to complete that
to get something
so i'm sitting there and i forgot what i
cashed it i'm like oh no i gotta do all
the silvers again the gold again oh man
and my friends are like bro you get
nothing that's just telling you what
your maximum capacity is so i was
completely fooled by this thing i'm
sitting there holding on to things
hoarding and then it got it got so bad
that i was doing strikes and i couldn't
pick up any laurels i'm like yo what's
going on i can't pick because i was at
the phone cause i'm thinking i was gonna
get something for the stupid dad kid so
stupid me fix that i got the uh
obviously the smg'd i haven't seen
anybody get that that's what actually
started me from continuing once i heard
the bug was out that people are not
getting the what is it the title
contained what's the name of it the
title the title which is not confusing
at all when we have titles in the game
and i'll have the title gun but what's
the title of the title the title of the
tablet what name is the title's title my
name was the title title
yeah
bro once i saw it and i like 750s i'm a
750 fan my but i'm with ue in the sense
that the weakness has always been
stability of 750 they hit hard but the
stability is usually bad and usually the
mag size is low and the reload speed is
low so what i heard about this one i'm
like okay cool and what is it the fourth
one is like grave
robber um vorpal i believe so i was like
all right i i like the the perk as a
person who uses the starting one yeah
the default everybody gets yeah but i
wanted more roles so that kind of
discouraged me from going hard because
i'm like if i'm i'm not going to play
this and i'm not going to be getting the
roles i would and um other than that i
just started doing some of the what is
it the platinum
cards where it's like you you pick an
activity
so i think it was me screaming a couple
other guys we were just in the uh throne
world and there's a
you know oh yeah
watch his videos he's a great content
creator and you know he found things so
i was involved with things there and
that was the extent of it but i'm just
kind of cooling out until the bugs get
removed because then i'll farm but i'm
gonna travel blank it's it is dropping
now yeah no it's always dropping now oh
okay it was fixed about 24 hours later
it was wednesday midday or something
because my video posted about 9 30 on
wednesday and then they fixed it about
what
got it all right i'll get back and i
literally was like
it's probably dropping from depositing
metals i will update the comment i will
update the description all of that stuff
if you have if you haven't seen my
guardian games guide
shameless plug please go watch it please
help support the channel as well on that
one
um
but yeah like that was i did a lot of
stuff that first day
and got nothing for it yeah
so like that's where a lot like i mean
they were they were looking for
responses on twitter because lyanna she
was asking be like hey what's everybody
seeing it seems like there's a bug
people are like four five six hours of
playing not one dropping yeah so i'm
just like yikes so i went through all
the other quest stuff but yeah i mean as
you said it's convoluted is a fair way
to describe it because
the way everything works is weird you've
got the quest shoot to score from zavala
where you go to the training playlist
and you get your buff
the buff is gonna last for the week so
you have the buff for competitive which
is or the yeah the competitive guardian
games playlist which launches on friday
so over the weekend you're gonna compete
and try and get the high enough score
first to la to light all the torches on
the right side of the platform
those are going to be for the score
based rewards so if you get bronze
silver gold and platinum
you'll get those rewards and then the
top 10 over the course of the three
weeks are going to be the ones that get
that special emblem
there is a bronze threshold in a bronze
buff there's a silver threshold in a
silver buff there's a gold threshold in
a gold buff there's a platinum threshold
there's no platinum buff and that bugs
the living hell out of me
really yeah there's no buff for getting
platinum it's just like all right you
got the gold buff now go try and get the
highest score platinum really doesn't
matter
basically at all it doesn't really do
anything in the practice it's gonna give
you something with competitive i get
that that's where you're gonna get your
rewards but there's no platinum buff and
i'm like why the inconsistency is like
the goal to be like oh well this one's
too good
just stop here
just weird to me and i don't know if
that's one of those things where they
didn't divide it up enough felt like
platinum would be too much but literally
in practice there's no point to do
anything besides gold and then you could
literally try and just get the best
score in the weekend and you would get
the same thing
and getting platinum is not overly that
difficult in the first place now getting
to the top ten percent i will be curious
to see what that takes i had one run
where i got 227 000 points
the threshold is 175.
so i've passed like i've got platinum on
a lot of my runs but i'm usually in the
like 180 190 range that one run i just
must have been playing with the try hard
somewhat early in the day and they were
just like kind of synergizing everything
together yeah
so we'll see what the top 10 percent
feels like maybe if you play early
you'll get in the top 10 percent because
most people haven't tried yet so maybe
trying on friday if you want to get like
you know your triumphs done you could do
that type of stuff but
yeah the strike scoring is nice to have
back i just wish they would kind of
one leave it there
and then two give you an incentive to do
that during the game because right now
as you guys say strikes are basically
mindless
and this is also one of the first times
they've done matchmaking on a 1550. now
i'm hoping this is a test
because you could do matchmaking on a
1550 nightmare fall and open that stuff
up for everybody and then you don't have
the annoyances of like well you can only
do hero unless you get a fire team
we can all do legend we they literally
proved it right here so if it doesn't
get into the game soon
that alone for me is one of those to
where it's like you just proved it works
yeah because i ran through i've done
i've got platinum on most of my runs
kill everything in 20 minutes it's
basically what you got to do yeah it's a
20 minute timer don't skip a bunch of
enemies
kill your champions and you're fi it's
like and don't die a ton right that's
the biggest thing
and some people are better that than
others you get some try hard groups and
you get the guys who are like
i feel like they woke up on the wrong
side of somebody else's bed for
like skill that day but
it's been weird the other half of the
platform
is the medallion battalion quest that
one comes from ava
and it's the amount of medallions that
you deposit or the metals i should say
but just whatever
and as you deposit x number so the first
one is like 60 points you would have to
do four platinums and then it's 120 then
180 then then 240. so to get all the way
to the platinum
[Music]
like torch that you land that you have
to light you have to deposit 240 points
worth of medallions in the podium over
the course of a week
that's just
tedious you think
and then on it's weird on top of that
because you light the torches and then
you get like a little gift from the
torch but then you go back to even it
says there's a package
but you don't open the package i don't
know if the rewards come from the tables
but the packages are still under eva for
a reason that aren't supposed to be but
i should be able to open four of those
packages for week one and i can't touch
any of them
so it's just it's it's weird like i just
not
doesn't feel polished and i don't mean
that in a bad way but that's just kind
of the nicest way i can say it no no i
feel i think
it is there any reason why we are
getting blues from either
can we can we can we can we stop with
the blues
like really like who is this helping
like you want to lose the blues no one
i just what my thing is i'm the guy i'm
the broke guardian i'm the guy that's
maximizing everything wasting resources
like ec he hates me like what are you
doing right i'm that guy every business
in real life yeah that's sort of kind of
but
anyway
so my thing is
i need resources man
give me purple so i could break these
down
there should be no blues and i just
don't understand this it's like it just
seems to still be going on so i want to
know how you feel travis like where are
we at with this
i'm sorry i just got a very disturbing
message from somebody on twitter oh okay
all right everything good
this is a message i got on twitter it
says
i opened the stream
zoomed in on you and licked your face on
my phone screen
that is all
that's what this says right here and i'm
sorry right when you called on me hey
guys i'm reading this going
last word
is a special campfire
[Laughter]
uh this guy's name is steven segal
steven seagull appreciate you brother
thanks for coming in and licking my face
man really matters
so anyway let's get back to the
issue
uh i was gonna say
yes i agree with you cog that uh you
should be able to gain resources i i
just think
there's two things one is making the
event
worth your time which i think is
really that's more for the hardcore
players or
maybe the casual players if they can get
something that they wouldn't normally
have access to but i i doubt that that's
a
an issue for them
um
the other way to do it is to give a
unique experience which which
i know i kind of don't want to talk
about what guardian games could have
been but in what in another sense like
we talk about it every year and every
year it seems like they don't change it
and it could have been something awesome
like how how hard cog do you think it
would have been
to make it a 3v3 v3 pvp mode where it's
titans versus warlocks versus hunters
and the first place gets a gold medal
and the second place gets a silver medal
on a bronze and then you go and deposit
it like how hard would that have been
like because you got to think like if
the halo multiplayer editor is anything
if has any dna in common with destiny
like that's literally a toggle it's like
add a third team you know reduced number
of players it even could have been
devil's 2v2v2 right
like that then it would have made an
actual pvp mode which feels to me more
like a guardian game sort of competitive
olympic event uh but
i just
that's the thing that really gets me is
the missed opportunity with like there's
so many better things i think guardian
games could have been and again i don't
want to just i don't want to be a
backseat developer and be like yeah like
this is what it could have it could have
been but
come on man come on right it could have
done that yeah absolutely right i think
the overall theme and and you said it i
think he and i have intimated as well as
like
let's be real the fun of destiny and the
subclasses are interbeefing with classes
right you know
like so if in theory the spirit of this
should literally have the classes
competing against each other just like
you said like how dope would that be
right like they're pre-made
what you know each individual class
represents the fire team in guardian
game and then it's the true
competition of who did better like i'm
with you i think that idea is fire it's
the spirit of what this is this what
we're doing is kind of like
facsimile
you know everybody just get out there
round about
compete each other through a score of of
that you don't actually see each other
so come on let us let us actually
compete against one another who's better
thank you
no yeah i mean same thing it's just
we've been
it's just the kind of the state of some
of these live events
where we are in these the blue drops
like we got okay blue drops aren't gonna
come from
playlist activities and we're like okay
how about the other stuff that i'm gonna
be doing or farming and then you get to
this point where
let me turn in
20 medals or whatever if your metal case
is full how much crap just went into you
your postmaster your item slots that
then you got to go delete
if it's not the worthwhile item i'm
going for
doesn't matter like if you want to give
me something for bronze give me a little
bit of glimmer give me
an enhancement core for silver like
stuff that is functional to some people
don't give me blues just for the sake of
you can't find anything else to put in
that slot that
or don't make that a thing one of the
two like either make bronze
give me something that i care about or
take the slot away that's all i'm saying
is
yeah it's like a 2v2v2 two titans two
hundreds two warlocks you could have
like pvp matches get crazy as you guys
have said you could do strikes and be
put people in strikes but then it's like
hey you actually get the gold medal for
you if you run through the strike and
kill the most people have the least
deaths and the kind of scores this like
balancing out somehow and you actually
see the little medal up here and be like
i kicked ass for my team that week or
that strike and that way in gambit you
know you win you lose type thing you
might win one for there's much more they
could do
and it is just one of those points to
where
you wonder the size of the live support
team you wonder the size of the people
making light bulb which we know that
development's going on from the big map
that we saw and then who's making season
17 who's making season 18 and you start
figuring out like how many different
like you start whittling away at the
entire staff of bungie and you get down
to the live service team and you're like
how many are left
and you gotta wonder because
the season team
we got a really cool season like short
tight story but really well told story
cool cinematic all of those things and
then we turn around and we get this type
of guardian games which is mostly a copy
with some tweaks like i enjoy the fact
that we get some cool music when we go
in the tower the torches are
[Music]
not necessary
i would say i understand kind of like
working your way up the ladders a little
bit
but as like is is the i mean is the
effort worth it there versus
you know it's just that would be the
question of
what are they allowed to do how much can
they do in the time that they're
allotted like how much work can be put
into these seasonal events how long in
development like you know precursor do
they get on all the stuff so mine's just
the wondering of that type of stuff air
appearance the same thing
it's been that way for three years now
so we've had that for a while
yeah so it's like that one and then the
fact that the air apparent catalyst
popped in my inventory mm-hmm
for me to re-earn even though i
literally have had it done for a while
so that was a weird bug so you see that
and i'm like yes i know that's still
there
um
i mean
i'm sorry
no i was like and then just the title
smg not dropping on day for the first 24
hours when you know that most people are
gonna play it and then you turn them off
of it
i was just like that's just one of it's
just a combination of things and that's
where i wonder
where all the you know
where the chips fall when it comes to
the live stuff i mean the elephant is in
the room it's just let's be honest like
seasonal events have just been bad for a
long time they just have been they just
you know
it the event you know it's not that good
when we keep getting the same structure
for the most part the same rewards for
the most part and not too much it's like
tweaks we've been getting little minor
tweaks to the same thing and and i don't
know what it is you know it could be
like you said you know it just could be
where the the resources are all the live
team is is in the state that it is and
this is all they they're capable of
doing based on everybody else on
lightfall and hopefully with the
acquisition
you know these type of things can change
because they need love i don't feel
these modes really add anything like
they used to i remember when they all
debuted like okay cool this this this is
a great start right this could evolve
into something great and the reality is
they've pretty much stayed a template
every year
exact same thing for the most part with
the same kind of rewards for the most
part and it's just you know we're just
going through the motions with it until
we get real change and i don't know if
that's going to happen and i'm curious
with the fact of a sony acquisition
does this increase the size of the live
team so that they could really make
substantial changes to these lives i
just don't
yeah i know you like i know where you at
because you like with the movies and
it's gonna make it smaller i'll give it
to you on that but it's like
i just don't know anymore like i'll be
honest like live events are to the point
where it's just like okay we know what
this is and i'll traverse
yeah we know what it is and i'll choose
whether to invest in that but you're
getting you're getting traffic i know
you you have strong thoughts on this
uh yeah i mean my thoughts are
it's funny
it's funny like peeking into the destiny
community every now and again because
you know i i spend a lot of my time
these days not being
playing other games just because i have
to for work you know i'm forced to kind
of experience other games through my
work in ign and i think that um
but a lot of destiny players are so used
to the status quo that they're unable to
dream bigger than destiny is right now
and i find that uh not super helpful uh
i think it lets bungie get away with a
lot that that we shouldn't let them get
away with you know we should we should
expect more than a seasonal event being
the exact same re-skinned activity your
year in and year out and we used to
right like when they did festival of the
lost the first couple times like every
year it was a little bit different it
was getting better and they were they
were they were fleshing it out and then
after a while they just started doing
the same thing and we complained for a
little bit and then we stopped
complaining and went oh well you know
it's a free event and oh well you know
bungie's working on other stuff and oh
blah blah it's just like yo
why are you
do you work for bungie are you on their
pr team like what what what is your
interest in trying to like pre-apologize
for bungie disappointing you you know
what i mean like it just because it's
the way it has been doesn't mean it's
all the way that it needs to be it
doesn't mean that it's good right it
doesn't mean that the just because it's
what's happened in the past it's what
it's good and also uh there are live
service games that provide content
at a better clip than than destiny does
granted
destiny is a different game it's got
lots of its own problems and
development issues and yada yada blah
blah but let bungie worry about those
problems you as a fan your job is to
just push them and never be satisfied
and i don't think that that's
entitled or uh naive i just think that
it's that's what we should be doing and
so i say
uh you know to people who who look at
this guardian games and think oh well
you know it is what it is it's a free
event it's just just stop it like that's
not helpful to anybody to just like
throw your hands in the air and say like
oh well because you know that's
how how long how sustainable is that how
long are people gonna keep playing
destiny if it's just that every year i
just let's make it better let's let's at
least push bungie to make it better
because i think i think it has so much
potential and it disappoints me to see
uh to seem like they're not even trying
really at this point with some of these
events it feels like so i know i think i
think it's very far past the e i think
it's valid because it's like i i think
what's happened in this specific case is
because we are still on the honeymoon of
witch queen and witch queen is so good
and season the risen is so good so it's
like okay
we had fun
all right guardian games we know but the
reality is if you compare it to other
live service models and events they it
doesn't stack and we still should hold
them to the firewood i'm in complete
agreement with that
yes
as for the sony thing i've already said
this a million times but i
i think it might result in them having a
smaller team but that's just beautiful
go on skype
they've been hiring so many people i
don't think their world can get much
smaller right now they just keep hiring
and hiring lately that's all i ever yeah
is people on twitter like hey it's my
first day it's my first day it's my
first day and then you see them hiring
for people for like an animation thing
or whatever so they feel like they're
definitely going to grow but it's like
yes only time will tell on that one but
no i mean for me it's like even just a
little stuff like it's only 500 laurels
that you can hold at a time it's so you
never quite get too many so then if you
get one you know if you do two
nightfalls in a row but you don't go
quite get enough or anything then you
gotta do go to a lower level card you
can't just learn the platinums and it's
got to be this weird rotation
and it just gets to be like why why does
it have to be that way why can't i buy
multiple cards at the same time that go
from a strike to the crucible otherwise
you're literally just going back and
forth from the tower i have a pc and an
ssd i feel so horrible i never even
remember for somebody playing on a ps4
or an xbox one trying to load in with an
old hard drive and you gotta go to the
tower so much in this thing
yeah you could go do strikes you could
go do crucible matches and you can get
some silvers or bronze but if you want
to be efficient with your time
then you're going to
definitely go to the tower a lot and
then if you right now the best thing to
do is strikes because you're killing a
lot of enemies getting a lot of laurels
and then you're getting the chances for
the golden platinum cards which are your
best chance to get the smg if you go to
a crucible match like control you get 15
laurels at the end and the only time i
was really getting
a lot of other stuff to drop if i
punched someone just a melee
i would get five randomly to drop
and then other than that if you did
manage to get a grenade kill or a
supergil you you might get a few from
there but like i'm gonna go spend 10
minutes in
a crucible match and get a bronze medal
in
20 laurels or i'm going to go into a
strike playlist that probably has bus
for me and if you match those you'll
blow through it in about the same amount
of time and walk it out there with like
120 to 150 laurels and then go do
something different like right now they
they don't that's again goes back to the
balancing of
some of the activities i know those are
basic playlists but strikes easily the
best one
like without a without a chance
and then like okay so then the pv people
feel like once again like why am i in
pvp
if i can't get the same balance out of
there and then you're pushing me back
into the strikes which i don't want to
do if it was even in pvp gambit and
strikes and then maybe you did a raid
like you could get i don't know a
thousand of them if you did an entire
raid like and completed the thing and
you got a thousand laurels but you can't
even hold a thousand laurels yeah so
it's just the weird time balance
equation and on top of just like the
little things that you guys are saying
it's
there hasn't been enough of a change
there's not a new exotic the smg is
you know it has a little bit to go for
but is it worth a lot of people grinding
for
probably not i mean it's got a unique cl
its origin trait so it's okay but on the
other side for me it's i'm you know
doing doing stuff for content and things
like that but after even after this
first week
you know you'll play on tuesday you i
could get my buff in one strike
i'm serious you get your buff in one
strike
and especially if you do the two
platinum torches this week i don't need
to do the battalion
or the medallion battalion quest for all
three weeks i don't need to turn in 240
points worth of medals
every week that's like you could get the
10 score if you were good enough the the
two weeks after do you get the gold buff
on tuesday friday do you strike once or
twice get a good score and bail and that
you could interact with it three times
i would be honest
you're dying over there and i don't know
if it's about me talking no no because
you got me thinking it is like
i have to confess like literally what
budget events have become to be now
is you've run out the mechanic is and i
run straight to everest and see what the
new outfits are gonna be what the new
emotes are gonna be and i'm spending
money that like that's my enjoyment oh
that's cool like the coolest thing
you don't say that kind of thing and
i wish dj oros was in the chat because i
he lives over there he he's funding all
the dlc's he's funding all the projects
thanks dj we appreciate you a long time
caller appreciate you first the long
time first time but um yeah it's just
that's where the i got a lot that's what
it's gonna be and it's okay oh the event
is actually cool too that kind of thing
yeah you know that's what it becomes for
me i'll be honest
so it's just this like weird state of
you know it's nice to mix it up and have
a seasonal event but when you've been
playing for a while it's like i know
rook he's you know pretty active in my
discord and stuff he didn't have the
machine gun i was like make sure you get
that but if somebody gets like one or
two smg's and to say you get a good one
there's not a lot of incentive
for a lot of yeah sure yeah
and it's always the incentive to get
like an emblem or something
for most of this stuff so and as always
most of the new stuff that's added is
eververse stuff and we're talking about
how the event is free but let's be
honest it's not free wales ship this
event right the people that well the
wallet warriors among us ship these
events and i think uh
that's like if you i don't know if you
guys played gentian impact but that's a
great example of a game there's a reason
i don't yeah i mean it's it's pve
focused but they their game is
completely free you don't have to pay
any of it they they also uh ship their
game and all the content is provided by
the fact that they have whales that just
like spend a ton of money in it right
because it's a gotcha game and uh i
think that that i mean
if i could if i could take a destiny fan
and open their eyes and show them all
the other games as a service games that
do things better than destiny i think it
would like blow their minds but destiny
players they just are too close to
destiny i think to realize uh some of
its shortcomings but uh you know i'm not
gonna be a guy who hates on destiny i'm
glad guardian games is going warlocks
hats off to you as long as as long as
hunters don't win i think we're all
happy
well the other piece we got um with
regards to the podcast was basically a
kind of a sandbox
q a is the best way i can kind of
describe it
retouched on flinch resistance which we
know people are going to be building
into they got a little more detail for
scalars on
what certain perks and synergies and
armor mods do rally barricade stability
to help if you want to build into flinch
and how much it does so they go through
a lot of detail on that i don't need to
go through all of the numbers it's not
necessary
they went over more on airborne
effectiveness and kind of really gave
you an idea of actually what accuracy
cones look like kind of aware things
like when you're looking down your
reticle what you're seeing this is one
of the first times i will say they put
pictures in there
keep doing that yes
because i don't need to go to shadow to
mercury's in a spreadsheet but i'm like
if you give me an image that looks like
this i can under
i can understand it for one and then i
can also explain it to somebody as well
with these
images it's not overly crazy difficult
when they show it this way and kind of
break it down it's still somewhat
technical but at least this way i have
an example to point to and be like
here's this universal image that we have
seen to explain why and the biggest
thing about airborne effectiveness is
if you build into it
you're not going to notice much
difference
in your current airborne effective play
if you don't build into it you are going
to need to be accurate with your shots
because
they said they're not going to have so
much rng on the accuracy but the aim
assist is basically going to be gone if
you don't build into it so if you can
theoretically hit your shots and you are
that good in the air
not much is going to change but as we
also joked previously on the podcast was
those of the people who think they're
good
and then the aim assist goes away the
game is going to change a little bit and
feel different especially for the
stompies that are like a big neutral
game clutch for a lot of people so i
will be curious to see when season 17
hits what the different feel of
everything is but
they go through more detail on can you
can you clarify precision aim assist and
how does it affect while airborne and
all of those things
um again lots of nuance and detail if
you want to look through what accuracy
cones look like and all of those things
you can do you guys want to go into the
detail on that or are you okay
kind of just kidding okay i'm okay
yeah yeah it's like that's for the
firing range guys
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's for the
firing range guys if you want to know
that your fallouts your cool guys your
drewskis they will all do that
and explain that in detail yeah i mean i
gave you a brief summary in my swag
video but yeah your detail on that stuff
is going to come from people who study
it on a daily basis and know how it's
going to affect i do like the fact that
they clarified they basically did a q a
for those guys who had more detailed
questions and that that part i do want
to encourage i did like the little
imagery as far as the cones and stuff
like that because for people who want to
get really to the minutia of how things
work in in destiny that's good and
they're being transparent so shout out
to them on that part but we don't have
to go into the details of that one
yeah i mean that's the nice thing is
like if you want to
if you want to learn more about the
minutia they're giving the resources to
people who are good at teaching that
more answers to the questions they have
and honestly i think this is just a big
thank you to chris proctor yes i think
with what he's been doing from the
podcast that he jumped on he was on dcp
he was on firing range they have a good
relationship with the bungie guys but he
has been very forthcoming i even think
it was
maybe it was josh hunt fallout had a
very specific question about something
you know about a video and he asked a
very specific question was able to get
an answer so there are certain people do
have connections to be able to get
answers to questions so there are people
who are going to be able to explain it
very well um and i'm honestly looking
forward to season 7 18 not 17 18 when a
lot of the in the weapon stats the
hidden ones are in the game your recoil
direction your aim assistant the now the
airborne effectiveness those are now
going to be shown on your weapon card
which is going to be a good thing
because
it's really annoying that stats are on
all of these weapons and you have to go
to the api to find them or look or no so
that will be very good especially as you
can build around airborne effectiveness
it's going to be an important thing so
just wanted to cover that real quick if
you want to know the minutia in the
detail there's a 9 000 word twab you can
try and wrap your head around and then
this is the q a for more questions that
came from that
as for other pvp things
uh they wanted to talk about scavenger
perk changes
they said all scavenger mods are
disabled in pvp scavenger doesn't matter
they're all disabled the main sentence
that i kind of wanted to touch on are
these two sets of bullet points with
regards to
with disabling ammo scavenger bots in
pvp are you trying to bring back a
double primary meta as some people have
asked no we do want running double
primaries to be more viable
and we still
and we want there to be fewer one-hit
kills but we don't want to eliminate
them entirely you still spawn in two
rounds
um
but you shouldn't be able to use your
special like a primary and this is them
getting to the point i think of as you
know i kind of said earlier
they're trying to get to where the steam
rolling doesn't turn into
a worse level of what it could be
because if somebody runs around with
like twit 10 rounds and a sniper rifle
just can't blame bam bam bam bam bam bam
they never have to move
that changes the game and the feel of
what they're trying to get for just more
or more you know more primary gun play
and stuff like that
um
they said one interesting side effect
maybe an indirect uh buff to the
strategy of running double primary to
starve your opponents of special ammo
actually i thought that was interesting
if you just run double primary and say
trials you're not going to give the
other team an extra shot right if you
just play that way right um
they say short range primary weapons
will have more of a role sidearms and
smg's everybody's been talking about it
potentially going up yep um
and then the final one this is kind of
the big one we've pushed the current pvp
ammo system as far as we can with this
change obviously scavengers are gone
they want you to have like one drip one
pickup from one person and that is it
they're trying to limit as much as they
can if this doesn't move the needle
we'll look at redesigning pvp ammo
economy entirely which would be a longer
term change
and this is where i wanted to ask you
guys with regards to special aim mode do
you feel like it's
is it going to go too far i don't how
could you see them redesigning it where
do you see the special ammo in the state
of this game travis seems like he's got
a thought about this one so i will tee
it up to you first sir where is special
ammo and what those weapons for you in
this game right now yeah i think we
talked about this like two episodes ago
but i i'm at the point now where i feel
like i get deja vu when they talk about
ammo economy with special weapons
because they've tried all this stuff
before and then it didn't work and then
they switched it back because i swear to
god we've had two or three times where
they've said all right we're gonna crack
back on a special ammo and we're gonna
reduce it so you only get you know two
shots and you only get one when you kill
people and then every single time they
do it the community feedback is it's
boring now everybody just uses pulse
rifles and then they go all right we'll
add shotguns back in and you know and
it's like we've had this conversation so
many times i just keep wondering like
which one is good game design because
just stick with that one if you really
believe in it and stop
swishing back and forth just like tell
me which one is the right way to do it
and let the community kind of
kind of uh
build themselves around that and then
and then tweak it because it seems like
we've talked about this on so many
episodes but like bungie doesn't believe
in their own ideas whether it's weapon
sunsetting and whether it's you know all
the stuff that they've just said we're
going to do this because it's the right
move to do from game design and the
community goes but we don't like it and
they go well if you don't like it then
forget it
it's just like
just just which one is correct please i
i'm not a game designer you tell me and
then let's just stick with that because
i i do
i i could see pvp certainly getting
boring without
special weapons really having a large
role but obviously you don't want that
role to be oversized so
there's got to be middle ground in here
somewhere i just don't know what it
looks like and
i'm waiting for bungie to tell me what
the right answer is because i just don't
i don't see this being any more
successful than the other two or three
times that they've tried this exact same
idea so
uh that's where i'm at with it
i'm just frustrated i'm exhausted having
this conversation with special ammo like
for real
yeah i was saying so so many times how
many times have we talked about it
just you and me like a lot a lot a lot
it it takes me back to d1 i remember an
aggressive change like this
and
everybody was out there using sidearm
that was like it forced sidearms to come
back at one point because no one was
using sidearms machine guns and
submachine guns and it's interesting
it's just like travis said that we went
through a couple of seasons
and the community was like nah this is
boring you know i want
and then here we are once again we do
not believe in the one-hit kill we are
pulling back the one-hit kill weapons
right so
again i i
i'm of a i'm a person i'm always going
to adjust
i'm at the point this is where me and
travis completely align i'm at the point
with bungie
where i know they're going to flip-flop
on something so i am going to have all
the available weapons when they flip
back to this other meta
that's how it
it's literally what you said it's hey we
believe and they give you this detailed
reason this is why it's good for the
health of the game this is going to be
the purity we're going to do this and
jumping in the air accuracy is going to
be reduced and we we don't want this one
hit kill steamrolling it creates a
negative effect okay cool you know what
i'm saying i got my sidearms i'm ready
to go i'm ready to go you know whatever
it is but it's like you said after a
while community gets
you know
we don't like this and what the hell are
you doing
i don't know what's i'm gonna try i
don't know what's the right but whatever
it is you gotta decide and i'm at the
point now
i'm ready because i know
six months to a year
mega
five comes out and we go oh my god data
nerf then reverse this change get ready
guys
you know this is back
it's it's just it's the nature of
destiny and i've never seen another game
like this i've never seen anything like
this better will shift and change like
no one's business
i don't know what to say so i'm ready
get ready what is it now so let's just
be clear
now we get let's say i'm a shotgun ape
i run around
i get my kills no scavenger so we get no
extra bullets but if i
right so if i kill someone with a
special i get one
right okay
that's you know that's what it i guess i
guess then the counter play is hey i'll
you know primary and then smg primary or
whatever
you kill me you don't get nothing now
you're running around the map with no
sniper ammo after a while after you get
your two kills or whatever if you didn't
kill another special ammo guy it'll be
interesting to see i don't know i don't
know what do you think like do you like
that meta do y'all like that
do you like the sidearm you know
alternative or do you guys like
the one-hit kill potential of the
snipers and the shotguns and the fusions
and stuff like that yeah my problem with
the uh you only get one ammo when you
kill things rule is that it means that
the only people who actually get to use
special weapons other players that are
really good anyway
because if you're really good and you're
sliding around and getting multi kills
of the shotgun you'll be able to feed
yourself enough ammo to like keep
getting kills but if you're not that
good of special weapons you're gonna
waste two shots bodying somebody and not
getting a kill and then uh and then
you're gonna have no ammo and you're
just gonna keep getting farmed and it's
like it's it's a weirdly like rich get
richer kind of situation and so
i i do like the idea of there being more
weapon variety and people being able to
use skill based weapons or weapons that
can one shot but they have big
disadvantages you've got to be good
you've got to charge up the fusion rifle
you've got to get a head shot on a
sniper rifle you like you know requires
accuracy or skill or what have you but
uh it's such a hard
uh line to walk and it seems like every
time bungie thinks that they're gonna
fix it we got this solution guys it's
gonna fix it they either don't believe
in themselves and they they trip over
themselves and they they
let the the community bully them back
into whatever position they were at
before or
the community just finds a workaround or
a loophole a way to just like damage
get around the situation and they're
like oh damn it we didn't expect the
players to do that and then it just
shifts the whole meta and then it just
changes everything so it's hard
it's hard to balance it yeah uh i do i
do think you shouldn't be able to just
run with a special all the time and have
unlimited ammo but um i don't know what
the right solution looks like and like i
said i'm just waiting for bungie to tell
me like you know because i don't know
either i i really don't i just i assume
that there's gotta be happy middle
ground uh but i don't know what that
looks like and they've certainly never
hit it before so yeah uh shout out real
quick to necromancer it's like they
could make fun game modes like special
weapons only or shotguns or power
elements only things like that make more
customization said that forever so
that's what we've been saying where's
the gun game like there's so many more
we've talked about that a lot like halo
just did that not the country oh yeah
sorry
um but yeah i mean speaking of halo you
pick up a sniper rifle you have a
certain amount of ammo and you're out
like that's the way they managed economy
before and now in this game where you
have these different weapons and these
slots where you always spawn with ammo
that's the issue
they've tried it with
maybe not having ammo and then you pick
up an ammo box or something like that
and they've had all these different ways
to know but it's like if you always
start with it
and you're good as you said you have the
ability to theoretically continue to
feed yourself unless people start
playing without the primaries then you
get in the double primary meta which
people tend to find boring
um but again it's hard to find that
middle ground of how do the rich not get
richer how does the casual person still
get enough ammo to practice and
theoretically get used to the gun
because they try and use that shotgun
but every time they get picked off or
they get vooped before they can use
their shotgun because they're not used
to using those then they don't get a
chance to it's
again i don't know honestly like if
you're the scavenger thing limits it
somebody in chat would just say cap off
how much you can have
just say like hey it's like if you get
up to four sniper rounds and you're in
your gun then that's the max like
there's no
20 reserves that you can go pick up if
you light up an entire team or something
you're not gonna go pick up four bricks
yeah and then just camp the lane with 20
more bullets like put a cap on four or
four like whatever it is in that point
and maybe that would be a way but that's
where they get into
you know redesigning the entire pvp mo
economy which would be something along
those lines of just saying hey fusion
shotgun specials those suckers cap
before if you get four use it or you
know you're not going to get any more
and that would be a different way for
them to go about it but it would be
a very different animal then you have
special inbox all those other things get
into crazy so it's
i'm with you guys i'm just going to play
what's presented to me
sometimes i'll use specials sometimes
i'll use primaries just kind of depends
on the feel
they're still in the game and they're
fun moments but also for people who can
just like run a train with multiple
special kills does get to be frustrating
if you're on the other side of it so i
get what they're trying to do but yeah
they've they've experimented a lot and i
don't know where it's going to land
either it's just
i did i did not expect you to be using
the front of the train sorry
i know i was not i was not expecting
that i was like
you know what you know actually thank
you for calling talking about it
yeah sorry buddy i just had to i was
like wow that was really aggressive um
listening to utaki i'm actually now
convinced that the closest bungee's ever
been is to when they made you go and get
crates and the reason the reason i say
that is because if you have highly
publicized like
special is going to be spawning here in
30 seconds you know get to this part of
the map and claim it
then then it becomes about you know
map control and like you know you're
working as a team and trying to like
control it and it's got more of like an
arena kind of shooter vibe where you can
choose what your power weapon is but you
you reach for it
um i think i think something like that
might make sense i don't know if they
should be starting everybody off with
special and then having people drop it
when they get kills and and even leave
open the door for somebody to just like
use
scavenger and grab a whole bunch of ammo
and all that junk i don't know if that's
the right solution they did and i
remember i remember the d1 days and they
were just like this creates a situation
of snowballing when one team controls
the other it's like
they got to decide they have to decide
what their game is yeah it's like they
have this but what i find funny
is to be maybe i'm looking more into it
than i should be it feels like a threat
if this doesn't move the needle we'll
look at redesigning the pvp animal
economy entirely which would be a it's
like a threat like if we don't like what
we see if these things are skilled
if your grades don't improve by the end
of next semester we need that we need
that mid-semester progress report to
come through and check the data they
start putting swabs out there and like
special ammo's too high you guys need to
use more primaries yeah
like i'm like am i in trouble like what
is this
i feel threatened
if you guys don't use more hand cannons
in crucible we will be
limiting your tv time after school
that's exactly what it is let's be real
trash like
they look at weapon usage and take
offense when there's certain archetypes
and things that are not being used and
now i gotta let daddy budget say yo you
got we this is this is the last midterm
that we go you gonna go through this we
gonna make some serious changes next
semester we're gonna we're getting you a
tutor we're gonna take you
it's gonna be serious we're gonna get
you in with the guidance counselor
here's my theory here's my theory cog
bungie's uh workforce is divided up
their sandbox team is divided up into
teams and each team is a type of weapon
a weapon type right so they've got the
fusion team and the auto rifle team
whichever whichever archetype is getting
used the least that group is in charge
of the sandbox next season they they
just take out all of their anger and
penta frustration about how little there
is being used out on the community
yes
it literally is that every season it's
that
every season down machine guns are
getting buffed then trace rifles
it's b they're basically alluding next
season get your machine guns ready get
your sidearms ready get your trace arms
ready because this is what you're gonna
do you haven't been listening you've
been bad in class and now it's time to
use these weapons we want you to use
these good weapons we made i mean come
on guys i'm worried about your choices
they brought gallihorn back in and
that's probably one of the most used
heavies in the entire game because of
ease of use by doing the one mission
catalyst is not that hard to do if you
go through and find those things and
then you've got one of the better guns
in the game for a general
level of people that can go after one
good gun and then now it's like okay and
then you gave rockets above finally
because you brought in the good gun and
you wanted it to be good
shocking that machine guns aren't being
used
one they don't do that much damage they
take up a heavy slot heavy slot is
always what you're going to use to
damage bosses so you need something that
hits linear's got a buff rockets did
finally get a buff grenade launchers
also feel like they're going to be the
next one in rotation after machine guns
because grenade launchers had the like
breach and clear and then after that
grenade launchers have been like sitting
on a shelf like yeah they've been
tanking like they don't they don't hit
that hard and you got to hit multiple
shots so it's this weird as you said
bungie's in the rotation of what part of
the metacycle it's about every six
seasons will rotate through heavies and
more pvp ammo less pvp ammo double
primaries get all the specials in there
and just ride the wave of the destiny
roller coaster and see which what's
going to spawn next because we don't
know we're going to get
yeah
i'll give them credit the only thing i
do like that they stand on was when they
gave us random rolls back that remember
that no random role met but they caved
that was just another example of what
you're saying they just did it in the
way that you liked because they said
random roles are too chaotic we're
taking them out of the game with destiny
2 so that we can give you curated roles
that feel a little better and have more
identity and they gave us all those
reasons and the community's like but we
don't like it and they were like well if
you don't like it then i guess forget
all that stuff we just told you you know
what i mean it's like play a population
brother just tell them tell me what's
real i don't understand play a
population brother
i sometimes i think they're too eager to
listen to their fans obviously you
should listen sun setting was too fast
sun setting was too fast they didn't get
a chance at it and i think
sometimes they think that their players
must know something that they don't and
it's like not really i i don't know if i
believe that i think that if you tell me
something is good design and you believe
that it's good game design then like
get after it man you do it i mean look
at look at how people responded to eldon
ring that's a developer that seems to go
out of their way to be like yo we don't
care what you say we're making the game
we want to make and you can like it or
not like it and people responded well to
that game that's not to say that you
shouldn't you should be arrogant and
never listen to your friends and stuff
like that but i think there's a middle
ground and sometimes bungie's a little
too quick to go on apology tours and and
over decisions on the flip side too
quick
when the community finds a loophole in
their own system and that becomes the
meta they don't
like that oh yeah they'll slap that
stuff down real fast yeah if there's a
if there's a nail that pokes out they
will
put that one back where it needs to be
they also pick weird fights
they'll they will
nerf something that's slightly out of
whack or or a way that somebody was
eliminating the grind oh here's a super
fast way to get these tokens you need
and then they'll get rid of that
immediately but then they'll let
cheating go on for like three years and
like just people just destroying trials
and they'll get rid of that
you know at super slow pace it's just
like i sometimes i question the the
priorities on that team but yeah yeah i
was always like an advertisement for
bungie to never hire me
yeah you heard me after the chances
don't play this on the interview
what do you have to say about this what
puts a vhs they're like oh
this is you really so you found that
that's me that's me yeah uh they also
talk about a bunch of weapon archetypes
just this is where they really went into
q and a's like the lightweight pulses is
the bx5 battler getting the same buff
yes it is retraced bath getting the
trace rifle buff yes
zooms fusion rifles yes they were
accurate no change to sidearms because
they figured they're going to be in a
place they go through all of those a
couple exotics in the same way risk
runners zoom is staying the same
lumina's
in the damage buff reduction is laminar
affected by a necrotic grip no they just
go through all these like rain
sorrow not a weapon i mean it's not it
never thought it was um
i was thinking about it
all weapons are weapons of sorrow i mean
if you want to go down that road sure
uh eyes of tomorrow they basically
explain the damage buff to it so that
one will get it's pretty much 30 across
the board i'm so excited
is gonna actually still have the
variable i thought that was actually
when i read the last one wave splitter
was actually supposed to have a set
damage and if you pick up an orb it's
going to get a buff now it's still going
to have the varial damage back and then
i'm like why
i'm like just just make it i'm all about
eyes of tomorrow that's right yeah
uh i did say in crafting if you craft a
weapon
and you pick like the like masterwork
trait like range or draw speed or
whatever
and you put two
enhanced traits on the weapon you can
get a gold border on your crafted weapon
now because you know some people were
not uh not happy the gold borders went
away so your your eyes will no longer
burn for those of you that care about
the aesthetics
i actually do care about that i do care
about it of course you both do of course
you do yeah i do it bothers me it does
it does bother me the dots and not the
border because i feel like i should
delete it i'm like oh that's that's a
mistake weapon let me throw it away
yeah
the winner is that it really doesn't
bother you
not that big of a deal
really it's not
it's not world ending i'll tell you that
look at look at the way you dress i
guess it doesn't oh my god jesus that's
a little boy hello
[Laughter]
that one bothered me it bothers me too
it does i like what i was like yeah it
messes up the synergy see you don't mask
the work that's what it is don't you i
masterwork
granted there's less of a point of it
now but yes i do master work the ones i
use
but the craft
thanks appreciate that unless that's
absolutely no yes all of my armor is
masterworked right now
i literally have like an arc of solar
avoiding a stasis masterwork piece of
armor
and all like wow
bro that's big from you
you were like a
it is a nine guy like you're right power
level but how long have i been playing
at some point i gotta put the golf balls
somewhere because like you committed
though like that was a big i remember
back in the day he was like i didn't
find nothing to commit to really to you
live and you would just sit on golf
balls
yeah you would no i get it for a while
but it got to a point where i was like
there even the seasonal ones that are
gifted to you in the season pass got to
be overflowing it's like i got to start
putting them somewhere so yes oh so they
became yeah they became like exotic
ciphers for you they they they were just
too much in this game yelling at you
it's like now you got the ones from last
season that you haven't even used that
so i gotta put those inside yes of
course so at some point yes i got there
but now the fact that i've mastered four
sets the only thing i would master now
is a random new exotic that i might get
but outside of that
i mean there's not yeah there's not a
whole lot of reason so but yes i do
masterwork all of those
um freelance trials this weekend will be
on altar of flame uh that one beat out
vostok and fragment so if you enjoy that
map then trials will be where you're at
um for those of you who are wondering
iron banner or not iron banner is going
to get us reworked iron banner is next
week
yep iron banners next week
no remind me 17. remind me to play it
next season 17 is the rework
but this iron banner is the last iron
banner for the season it is also
the last iron banner that you can turn
in tokens because all of your tokens are
going to be wiped out at the end of the
season so i have like two thousand i
gotta turn them all in turn in all your
tokens do the quest if you want it and
between trials and iron banner these
last few weeks there are certain weapons
messenger and shire's wrath will be gone
now i think you've missed the weekends
that they were adept but if you even
want a normal role on those things
get some grinding in use the tokens and
use those engrams
so
make sure
you guys are running out of time if you
want anything from iron banner if you
want anything from trials now is your
time to put the work in over the next
couple of weeks just wanted to call that
one out
uh other than that
the contender's boon i already said it
only goes up to gold there is no
platinum boone which is just frustrating
uh the shoot to score clarification
competitive playlist and figured that
would open up then
uh other than that they're basically
most of the supers like weapons of light
or
the word of dawn not word of dawn yeah
word of dawn but then weapons of light
well of radiance if you get kills while
those supers are active on you you those
do not count towards
metals right now
so like the strike scoring metals so if
you stand in a well of radiance and you
shoot stuff you do not get
the metals for like you know strike
sprees or anything like that
other than that that's most of the swab
really
got a new map and trials or a map voted
for yeah we voted we're gonna talk about
that i just said it yeah
yeah yeah i know but we how do we feel
about it do you like the map would you
have rather had vostok or fragment
no alter flame's clearly the best one
yes like it was actually pretty close 44
and 36 that was fragment was definitely
the minority for sure and that's i don't
like that map anyway so that's fine
um ultra flame and vostok
i could have gone probably either way on
that one
yeah i like all the flame but
well stuck i love hate with it yeah
i mean they both tend to lead to very
specific places to fight chosen
altar of lame
lame yo he crazy
damn
damn
i will say the side that has the uh
the head glitching on the stairs that's
oh that's really the problem with that
map is one side is exactly better yeah
the one coming from what c point down
looking out yeah it's still a good map
though
uh i wanted to ask you guys what do you
think season 17 is going to be about
um
then we hear rumors of um
what was it rasputin i thought we had
rumors of it it's time for him right
isn't it i mean i've heard rumors but it
seems he's got he's got to get his exo
body that's what you can do
get a little exo body we gotta see anna
bay
in the bay see her come out see anna bay
come outside you know what i'm saying we
don't know what's going on with her and
last thing we heard he got downloaded
into a engram he's an engram right here
i think he's worried he's an sd card or
somebody right now so you know you guys
see what's going on he's the most
useless war mine during the whole
situation like he just got
shut down and neutered immediately
darkness was like earth's protector yeah
yeah dawn this is like stop that so that
we got to see what's going on with him
and then
i doubt siva yeah but i really don't
trust i doubt siva but to me my main
thing is the dungeon excuse me the
dungeon is this coming season yes but my
question really is
after that which was season 18
what race are we gonna get what
returning raid and i want to know if
it's time for the king's fall like when
are we gonna get the
king's fall theoretically would make
sense this time
if you're going to stick with the hive
raid
but it is also a hive taken
again
um
theoretically the dungeon i think we
were talking about it last time could
theoretically be like vex
because we haven't had that in a while
or yeah
i don't want to score in one but again
we could get one of those if it's
thematically fitting as well but for the
raid it's like
i would like to see the complete shift
of wrath of the machine
just because
we don't have anything else like in the
game basically
it's very unique you have the zamboni
you have the axis fight you have all of
the pieces to that which are
um
just very unique um
and i like the fact that those are
i wonder how they would do the weapons
and all that type of stuff um
there's a lot of throwing balls around
in the early part so you've got that
part but access is cool i mean you got
the dunking mechanics
fall though that has some interesting
has the more boss fights though so i
wonder which one like on a work front
would be harder to pull together because
king's fall is the longest raid minus
last wish probably those are probably
about equivalent but it is one of the
longest raids
most encounters most places things could
probably go wrong cog sites
um
i don't know like i could see either one
i i i will laugh real hard and also be
kind of have it a hilarious point if
they bring back crota's end just to
troll everyone because everyone is
between king's fall
and wrath of the machine and if they're
just like huh look at that we got
criticism i think it's gonna be
hilarious yo that would be hilarious
i think that would be the funny part
no i was like i mean for the story i'm
curious to see because
iron banner
is getting a rework
title is involved somehow she has ideas
for the reworks so is there gonna be
is kyle gonna be hanging up out by the
big giant fire fire urn with like and
maybe she could be one of i'd love to
actually see her just chilling out in
the tower just like you got lord saladin
and then you got like nine foot 14 inch
tall title over there just
just the chunk sitting up there the
cabal standing in the tower and be like
and she's like you know the yeah i just
think that would be hilarious it would
never happen it would be funny um
so that might be its own little like
probably have maybe have some voiceover
lines i really don't know where they're
going with the story because they have
been so tight-lipped the season 17
narrative writers have been so excited
about it i don't know where they're
gonna go i feel like as it's
i think jarvis said it last time the
season after an expansion is usually
like the cool season like one of the
bigger seasons
so i think this is where we're gonna get
a cool story but i feel like it could go
anywhere because it's so far away from
lightfall it doesn't have to connect to
it it's not like season 19 which has to
like lead into nightfall it can be
whatever they want
and i just i don't even know where to
speculate at this point
travis yeah
uh
do you even have like a one i have no
idea i was like do you even have like a
race that you wanted what race do you
want involved in the story here
uh
i want
the witness to show up next season and
just start killing fools and then i want
us to get a fourth playable guardian
race uh hive light bearers and then i
you know wanna
all the new elements to be added and i'm
excited but uh
mostly i'm excited about the sandbox
changes the uh rework of solar i'm not
super i don't have huge lofty
expectations about the seasonal content
i'm mostly thinking that they're going
to rely on kind of like the sandbox and
those little things to carry them and
the dungeon i think the dungeon would be
great but uh
yeah yeah i don't know i have no idea
where they're going to go with the story
because we know they're playing a
waiting game we know the witness isn't
going to show up season 17.
so
we're probably just going to be doing
other stuff but i hope that everything
we do
has something to do with the coming
witness i want us to get to know the
witness before he shows up uh before
they show up i guess
and um
i would like
that kind of momentum that we felt
building going to the witch queen to
start now
i mean that's what i want i want i don't
want it to just be hey we saw a cut
scene that we didn't hear from the
witness until
they showed up i want i want to
typically like
yeah we're i don't want it to be typical
bungie i want it to be like you're
building this guy like we're we're kind
of dancing with some of his agents we
already met rock we're already fighting
some of his his disciples literally and
so i think um
i think we need to
they need to keep that momentum and not
get lost in like side stories
but i think they're gonna get lost i
think they're going to get lost
yeah i think whatever they're going to
but i would love it if they didn't do
that instead focused on the story so
your thoughts really any
requests i mean we kind of talked
through the dungeon last time i think
vex would be unique
um
i will say the precedent of what rolk
being so different say if it's like a
vex dungeon i don't want it to just be
like a minotaur in the end again like
ministers i always feel like are the
bosses because they're the ones that
probably scale up the biggest
and also i'm sitting here thinking
through um
wyverns wyverns are frustrating so those
those get to be a little bit annoying
yeah um
but i mean the dungeons they do always
nail so i mean i'm not worried i always
enjoy those the
you know whether it be the lore the
event of it the encounters just the fact
that they're usually built to be
soloable of course i'm kind of biased on
that one
um
so if they do that type of link if it is
like a vex related dungeon i'd be
curious because we really did i mean we
got cabal we got hive going on there's a
little bit taken scorn there's a little
mix of all that stuff going on there's
been nothing from the vex
yeah they've been quiet i mean the other
option in my head would be fallen but we
got grasp of avarice we got that one
already
and then
if the dungeon doesn't have any tie-in
with the lore of the season that's going
to be weird so it does feel like vex
might be involved because we got to kind
of know what they're doing last time we
heard about them was quarrio with
splicers
so i guess
also what's his face his planet got
taken and then
he became like a friendly vex harpy
he was always grumpy the grumpy
scientific
one-armed boy yeah
oh forget this i miss him
stinkiest character and yes
objective information
you know how i should remember that
because people called
said that i reminded them of astromere
for like the first year of fire team
chat they're like he's just asher mirror
this annoying old guy and i was like
true
fair
yo you got it on attribute of destiny i
am
but i do have his personality yes
yeah yeah
he's a little bernie sanders-esque
i don't care about my pride i'm just
chasing the giggles over here for the
content for the content
there we go that's what that's what i'll
do for the gcx shirt if i could do uh
thai guy asher be your situation yeah
there's here
but yeah there's your personality like
he
he got he's like a a thing now like a
harpy or so he's like assimilated with
the vex
during that whole thing that's the rumor
so we got like a friendly vex
con you know concert and the theme of
like because they seem like each race
would be having a friend
you know what i'm saying you know like
that's where it seems like myth rags
we're going to say
exactly the vex we need something
because they don't have the problem with
the vex is they don't they did a hive
mind
network so they don't have a singular
entity and
they kind of need that that's what kind
of the effects they're yeah they're like
the interesting work based i mean for
star trek reference there is no
i mean theoretically if you get in the
movie there's like the one lady leader
but i mean theoretically like it's a
collective
per se yeah it's like cory has been kind
of a high up but it is hard to get
as you said kind of a connection to them
because they are they are so alien
there's no i mean even
oryx you could you gotta feel he was a
dad pissed off because you killed a son
what'd you do to the vex well they
travel they are forever existent through
all of time and they are just a machine
race of vex milk like there's no
attachment there so that is a difficult
one to sell
which is why i like the hive and the
witness and
you know i'd be cool if they did some
crazy other you know
disciple
crazy disciple like weird boss that
comes in to play out of nowhere so
that'll be dope
i'd be happy to see more unique bosses
yeah new new new exactly yeah i could
hope for the momentum if i could hope
for a new i just don't have high
expectations usually because like the
expansions are so big
isn't there a glimmer of hope e a little
bit just based on the hype that the the
bungie employees seem to be having for
the season that they haven't really had
before do you feel that there's a chance
we'll get something that we don't expect
and it won't just be another season
where we fight some nameless you know
faction and then go back to the way
things were
any chance i i want to say small because
i never expected um i never expected
rolk and i never expected the witness so
i feel like they have to be opening the
door to new things
to some extent otherwise there's no way
we're ever going to see anything crazier
than zevo wrath and like that's it
because if it's like if rolk exists
forgot about her we still got this yeah
yeah we still see who's where i picture
light falls she's outside that feels
like zevu
is going to get the build up the
lightfall then the maybe the witness
into the final shape that's my poor
speculation
but the fact that roelk exists the fact
that we've seen the witness in a trailer
feels like maybe there could be
something like that
coming at some point that you've got to
have something unique if there can be
i don't know if we go into the pyramid
ship on europa for example because we
did a mission in there
which was really cool and enjoyed it you
could theoretically also have a dungeon
based in a pyramid ship and who knows
what else has been
locked up in a pyramid somewhere i mean
i could see them go in that direction
which would be cool to keep it unique i
just
i think that would be expecting a lot
right now
but if they could do it i'd love it i
absolutely would
yeah i don't know i think next week we
got iron banner coming so they'll do
next week fairly quiet and then the
final week
uh right when i get back from seeing my
brother in austin
um is when they're gonna drop trailer
swab it's literally the week before is
when they drop our seasons so
next week is going to be iron banner
week two of guardian games kind of chill
vibes and then do what you got to do
farm your machine guns get all that
stuff out of the way and then the final
week which is
1918
17th
17th is gonna be the final week um
and that's when i think all the season
stuff's gonna explode because they won't
say anything until they do that trailer
now would i love it
if they literally
only talked about sandbox only talked
about this stuff and actually did no
marketing for a season and just said
download it and log in and see what
happens i know they won't but i wish
they would one time
it's like it's like you don't want
people to play the game how do you think
people find out about the new content
you think that they think as soon as
people log in it would be spoiled
everywhere every article itunes would be
like the new season is this this that in
the up like it would take five seconds
i'm sure and all of the people who get
pre-access to it would publish
at reset on the 24th like it would be
out there but just to be able to have
access to log in and not know and just
be like all right where are we going
i don't know if you know this but news
isn't news if it already happened and
it's out and anybody can play it you
know what i mean like they have to build
hype before i know that i literally said
it's not going to happen
but i wish once it kind of would that's
all i'm saying
you're like you're such a hipster you're
like a person to a marketing team like
you
i can't do anything with you really
how are you the first amish destiny
player how is this what's possible i
don't even understand
that's not quite here that's not your
best reference i'll be honest but you
just don't want to you know you just
shut up shout out real quick to colin
wheeler hot love love the podcast for
months thank you for the hard work we
are very
happy to have you here colin thank you
for the listens and the enjoyment um
no i get it no no but it's just like
it'd be one of those things as like a
big mystery to figure out where this
like that would be something for
um like light not yeah no final shape
because that is gonna be the last
expansion of this season
and if they're like hey we need we're
gonna fight the witness and this is
gonna be the campaign
yeah we probably expect that but on the
other side it'd be nice not to have all
the information going in and i know they
have to sell it so i know it makes zero
sense that's just a preference of
let me play a game and not know what's
going on when i play it
and know what this is i know what this
is
your single-player sensibilities are
kicking in yeah and i know it's not ever
going to happen so i accept that it's
just like i get it you like you like the
you like the surprise you like to not
know you want the big reveal
and it just i i feel for you bro i do
understand where you're going but it
ain't never good i know i guess i accept
that you work in the wrong industry you
have to cover the news
it's that's what i'm saying it's a
personal one and i know it doesn't make
any sense i fully accepted that you guys
i i wanna i i get it i get it you're an
idealist to the bitter end yeah i was
like
i'm gonna see that stuff as probably as
soon as it comes out break that trailer
down frame by frame you know what's
going to happen but ck just got you he
said no no
no tk doesn't understand tk says you as
an individual can choose to avoid any
spoilers and marketing material no no
you can do that t.k
myself
just
stay low
just yeah
yeah that's not that's not the smart
business decision so that's that's the
other side
you won't be spoiled but he'll be
looking for a new source of income
you haven't published a video in two
weeks you publish your video on the
first day but youtube's not going to
like that very much
the algorithm doesn't like that kind of
thing so no that's not really not going
to play dice but i feel the algorithm
i'll hail the confusing as hell
algorithm but
um
that's just i mean as i said it's a
personal want to like
you know first time i saw stormvale
castle in eldering is like that's a cool
moment
single player sensibilities so that's
but that's the i like
if they walk a balance of not giving us
too much
that's what i like that's where it's
like not for you you know if you can
felt which queen trailer was well
marketing was too much
what part what part annoyed you with
witch queen trailer which queen was
reasonable
okay um
they didn't they didn't show witness we
didn't no one knew it right didn't know
about the witness didn't know how we
were gonna get told the whole story
didn't know the back story didn't know
the turn
um
everybody expected we were
that it's
it is spoiled guardians
high viper yeah
would have been cool like that would
have been we did no damn it she got out
of the crystal
yeah that was the end of the season so
it's just it's you know it
el i would say which queen was better
than forsaken because forsaken was one
moment they could have been like hey
you've got
you know aldrin saw of letting out the
barons and all of those things and you
could have like you know maybe a mystery
as to who got shot or something like
that but it's just the fact that it was
in the trailer
who shot you what if it was a mystery of
like no but it was like it was faded out
and it's like one of the vanguard could
have been the one shot as well knowing
it was kade like then you still have the
marketing guy but then you gotta go find
out who it is which queen has got it
yeah who done it's like yeah you're
going into agatha christie murder
mystery but yeah
no i was like which queen was not which
queen is not quite as egregious as
forsaken in my book so for say yeah i
remember the fight season you were
disgusted you were like what they gave
it away
it was the premise of the
you're allowed to have a personal
preference but you should also be not be
offended when somebody asks you to
explain your personal preference and
give any justification yeah it's because
i don't i don't want like what is the
what it's like going to see um going to
see a very specific marvel movie and
then being being shown a very specific
moment and there's like in avengers in
game for example i could pick two and if
you show me either one of those i'm
gonna be mad it's like in forsaken we
got one yeah it's like very beginning of
the game but i don't need to know that
before i even get there
like i don't want to know in a movie
that's why like movie trailers
star wars the force awakens was one of
my favorite movie trailers because it
showed so little
but also
it was like it's 100 a star wars movie
but didn't tell me what was gonna happen
it gave me like inklings and ideas but
didn't spoil anything it wasn't like
well well we know this is actually all
star wars movies are like that which in
fact star wars even does something where
they
add fake scenes that aren't actually in
the video yeah
just to throw people off
like that so i agree with you
holistically but i also think like
there's a certain amount of information
you have to know to know if you want to
even buy something and i get that but
it's just like if you're walking the
line
like do you go and see movies without
knowing what genre they're in you're
like i wonder if it's going to be a
western or yeah you just buy the ticket
based on the name and you just go
completely of course i don't do that and
that's why i said like which queen was a
better balance of that than i felt you
know
yeah the hive guardians would have been
a cool surprise but you know there was
things that we didn't know were going to
happen that we got later on so i felt
like it was a better balance personally
yeah shout out back he said they had to
fire up the community before before
saying how pissed off both were that is
true i remember
yeah i'm buying for
like hunters were pissed like the whole
it was it was a thing we were like yo i
love kate he would let's be honest kate
was low-key a crutch to the series and
it says that he was so beloved yeah like
like he let he carried d1 for a lot when
they didn't really have good
storytelling beats and he would just
come in and crack his little jokes and
be funny
taking king like he carried a lot of
destiny so i get it i do get it it's
just like i said the marketing that this
team is they're just
magicians with working emotions and
getting the right beats and getting the
musical tone and theme of the season to
get you emotionally connected and yeah i
i i think it the train will continue to
to ease disgust
i understand it and it's just again like
it's a person and that's why i said i
feel like it's been getting better where
we've been getting teasers in some but
not all of it which i appreciate so
there you go yeah now we get all of our
news through uh
uh leaks yeah yes through uh also that's
how i found out that there were gonna be
hive light bearers
remember
the big whole leak that happened like
six months before which queen was
announced until i found out about it
yeah yes sir yeah trying to avoid the
leaks if possible then you get to a
point of
uh yeah trailers versus leaks is all
different matter entirely so
well that is about all we got just us uh
the next couple of weeks we have some
very
um very good guests coming we've got two
pvp
focused very good content creators we've
got shadow next week if you guys know
him i know he just cracked 100 000 subs
does some very cool content myth busting
and other stuff and then we've got
castle coming after that
so two very good
guests to talk about basically the hype
into whatever we know and then on the
19th which is going to be right before
the season launches that'll be castle so
that'll be
like trailer twab whatever they do in
between there so we've got a couple of
cool ones coming so i just want to let
you guys know what to know for the next
couple of weeks
um but yeah it's always fun just to chat
with the three of us and just mix it up
for a little bit get off on random
topics and
speculate give each other a hard time
you know i'm gonna have to go edit the
opening of the show and if you missed it
well
hopefully it's gonna be gone sooner than
later
that's getting deleted
hey you know i got no stake in this i'm
not drawing a paycheck so it's like
the hell with your
i'm just here to throw a wrench into
things but uh i'm just here to get you
shut down thanks man thanks bud
appreciate that
it's going to be really hard to host
this thing in the future
that's right
uh but yeah like as we always do for a
wrap up um
can you tell us what you're working on
or is this the next big secret travis
what you got
me yeah
yeah i think i mentioned at the top of
the show but i'm i'm reviewing uh evil
dead i'm doing a preview for uh
some other games um yeah it's it's sort
of a quieter season so uh in the in the
reviews world so i've been getting some
some stuff done i'm still the
highest volume reviewer at ign i know
that's actually really awesome it's just
it's pretty now is it my volume of views
or like number of games or both
number of
rev games reviews okay yeah and actually
the next the next person behind me is
like at four or five reviews i've done
like 15 16. yeah
yeah this year yeah i'm pretty high up
there yeah i was like
they need to at all this crap that
you've had to deal with i feel like at
some point what's the game is there
anything like what do you want now that
halo went to ryan mccaffrey i knew
obviously nobody's stealing that from
him no one he's stealing uh but is there
anything all all these like you know all
the pain that you're putting in is there
anything you have your eyes on like hey
when that thing i've heard about can i
get that like is there one that you do
want at some point that you've heard of
at least
yeah i mean even if there was one i
wanted i don't think i would get it to
be honest with you but i will say the
one game that i am lucky to review and
it seems like i will continue to be able
to review it is destiny so i kind of
have my game i get to review destiny
every year when it comes out that's
that's
like
yeah i'm i'm the expert on it it makes
just sense for me to review it so i
already get my dream game and honestly i
don't mind reviewing bad games some
people it really bothers to me it just
you know it makes me
roll my eyes a couple times i have a
laugh and then most importantly i get to
go out and tell people to not play it
which i think is a valuable service like
you need somebody like that because be
like this game is terrible don't waste
your time on it yeah i mean there's some
games where you're just you're howling
at the win like postal four i don't
think anybody who wasn't gonna play that
game
now wasn't gonna play it because my
review but i do think that like nerf
legends i stopped a lot of moms from
buying a really bad game for their kids
you know what i mean like that was real
i saw people in the comments being like
oh my god i bought this as a christmas
gift for my kid i need to return it like
stuff like that
nerf legends oh because that's like the
old yeah that is a good game yeah that's
a territory for a kid yeah yes for sure
but yeah you're okay being the bad guy
and no skin off your back so no they
have the right person to deal with that
comment and you're like i don't care it
was a terrible game perfect i don't i
don't care man
you're
it doesn't bother me at all some
reviewers some people who produce
content they get really hurt when people
comment on theirs i don't care at all i
really don't that's something you learn
about yourself when you start making
content is like how you react to
negative feedback because apparently i'm
just a sociopath
apparently i just have
no
empathy or
shame just at all so no anyway yeah
willing to call a spade a spade and
somebody actually does need to do that
it does the service everything yeah
it's a service man um
also uh this last episode of
uh bitcast was our 200th episode
which obviously i take full credit for
all 200 episodes
somebody who was on the show for hey
that happened with a fire tv i was on
the show for like 30 episodes and it was
like episode 300 and i was like what up
guys it's me it's all me
like i was here for like just about a
year thanks
yeah by a year see you boys um so yeah
but but you should watch it a cog is on
it eat bontus is on it there you guys
both were on that episode yeah i don't
know you people at the same time no no i
can't i was very early like i was like
y'all went live almost no i was sad
i was cooking and i jumped in at about
11-ish that was about an hour after
start hour and 15 or so dope i was
getting some stuff in the oven and i was
like all right i'll get in line
for my spots of chat and stuff and
uh somebody came in and
like it was a brap came in i think it
just like came in with the casey kasem
voice and just like took over the entire
thing for a minute i was like all right
i'll just play
yeah that was pretty funny yeah uh but
anyway i didn't actually say a lot on
that episode i mostly was just listening
to other people tell their stories but
you can watch me say things uh this
sunday i think it's happening it's
mother's day but i think we're still
yeah
uh but are you guys doing an episode on
mother's day do you guys not care about
your moms yeah we just we like whatever
the matrix
anyway uh so yeah i think we're doing an
episode this week so you can hear me get
in a fight with a lawyer and and
probably beat him i mean he usually do
let's let's be honest i'm the best uh
yeah other than that
i love you guys cog e i'm so excited to
see you guys at gci i know yes
that's what i'm excited about a month
out now that's really exciting meet you
guys in person i bought my two thousand
dollar plane ticket sorry about that
yeah but thanks for the commitment
appreciate that
and uh i think we're gonna do a show in
person we got to i'm bringing equipment
bro i'm bringing it ahead it's like
yeah then i'm going to record an episode
of big castle over there because the
xbox show is happening yeah i gotta do
the same thing sunday yeah i just
ordered sure what is the high speed
package for your room sir
yeah i mean i i assume i'll get that
it's not part of the default do they
have high speed in florida is that a
thing
yeah they florida florida street it gets
to travel through the swamp it's a
little bit the yeah a little bit the
ping is pretty bad because the all the
lines are chomped on by alligators but
you know
here we go i gotta pick i was gonna pick
better lighting this time but if we do
about a beach in the pool
yeah or we'll find a place for them
super excited to do that with you guys
and i just want to say like i know i'm
more trouble than i'm worth as a uh as a
friend and somebody that you know shows
with but i hope you know it's all love
and and you guys are awesome
also don't forget to check out tinder x
xyz yeah
really
really out here
trying to give you free nude pins or
something
dating sites coming through the chat
tonight trying to spam so yeah we'll
keep those out of there yeah
we gotta make sure
nato's tinder is not listed here
let me get my extra my side income man
out here yeah
i'm on yeah don't forget to join uh hogs
only fans these guys
my bots are acting up i apologize yeah
what about you guys outside yeah man i'm
excited for gcx i've been prepping i got
um you know check tickets everything's
cool can't get a conference room but um
high speed internet it will be there and
then we got days we gonna hang out so
i'm excited about that to see everybody
back for daddy's in the chat he's gonna
be there yes a lot of clan gonna be
there good to see everyone um as far as
duke got things cooking getting ready
for um
the uh what you call the bethesda
microsoft stuff as well iop tons of
stuff cooking so i'm excited for that
i'm in the same position as trav i'm
gonna have to bring the laptop bring all
stuff because i'm gonna be actually
jumping into my own show
on sunday
so i can't party too hard with y'all on
saturday that i will probably get my
drink on my chill you know but i can't
go party actually you can just get into
the advanced gg after party on sunday
night after the show
powder get that make sure you get your
powder it's gonna be lit it's gonna be a
powder party you gotta participate trav
you're going to have
a powder for you i i am going to make
sure that you have a great lighting and
microphone on sunday morning from your
hospital bed
i think you're going to be
really getting stomach pumped from
alcohol poisoning
it'll be exactly that way for
first live stream from an ambulance
would be great
bro
it's gonna be interesting but yeah i got
two shows to do right on saturday we got
the live show for the xbox uh microsoft
but that's the conference and then i
think maddie wants to do something so
we'll see we'll figure it out but i i
got all my equipment ready and we
definitely have to do some for even if
it's already recorded
last word all three of us together
recall even if it's just an impressions
live at gcx i want margaritas in hand i
want beach backdrops i want travis out
there with the suit in the hot sun and
because going to die in that floor he
don't know what you're going to do
he's going to die in that suit
i've been in the middle eastern deserts
in a full suit i think i'll be let's go
i'll be let's go let me see
he bringing the dead cracks what you're
doing
[Laughter]
i've never owned a pair of cowboy boots
either thank you very much
that would be wow
no seriously never
i've never put my foot in a cowboy boot
my cap wouldn't fit in a cowboy boot are
you kidding me big cat big cats
but where the heck though
low tie and a pair of spurs personally
the only thing i've got is the asses
chaps i'm sorry i'm just kidding
don't bring it
up
the chat
for the pool i'm good to go
but rather we bring the gold figure no
don't break that but um anyway it's
going to be lit i'm really excited to do
that type of show with y'all that should
be fun
i'll say all three of us together to be
trapped i mean for the first time in the
flesh no
and every time we give him a hug we're
just going to like give him a bear hug
and then just like pop his back
yeah yeah just squeeze him squeeze some
kind of feeling
you guys are gonna be shocked at how
short i am it's really
it's really i'm uh i just got the body
of i've got the body of present day
bernie sanders for sure you guys are
gonna be alarmed it's gonna be great so
i'm very
excited be good i i haven't met anybody
i stream with a podcast with anybody
this is a richard house teddy teddy but
what might be coming right
it might be i met him
he stayed at my place for for a week
yeah he did say right but everyone else
yeah will be your first time that'll be
dope yeah
everybody's gonna meet everybody
that's right what you got going on
um
yeah no in between guardian games
content just uh potentially either
streaming some destiny or working into
my next indies and then of course just
happy to have uh
some advanced gigi hydration so this is
non-caffeine no excuse trav trap door
excuse get the powder now we got to get
it yeah
no addiction no
totally for sure powder eight ounces on
the cut you're good to go
same [ __ ] your nose wipe your nose ten
percent with uh
cody bartus
that powder that's a guy a code thai
i don't think you want me slinging
powder i i look like the guy who's who
does too much powder is what my role is
i
sample my own product perfect marketing
as long as you don't go partner with
that one congr congressman i saw on the
news doing some stuff you're probably
okay so
i'll probably set up my briefcase
pop up in a briefcase it's just filled
with little white
little bags of white powder
you go through you go through airport
security and they open and they're like
we're gonna be here for a while sir
we're gonna have to test every one of
these that's right that's right listen
man it'll be good that's gonna be fun
well if you're in a suit the entire time
if you're in a suit
the entire time you are definitely gonna
get a little toasty nice thing about the
leviathan slash rose and shingle creek
is it is all indoors so you won't
technically have to go outside so it's
up to
you the life i live already never going
outside sounds fantastic that's what
most of us do now right
all right well that was like the longest
30 minute outro we've ever had yeah we
made up the whole show for that yep
uh no honestly gcx is very exciting it's
coming very uh my wife is just gonna get
to chill by the pool for like four days
not have to worry about me or the dogs
or anything so she always has fun for a
couple days when i'm like you're busy on
the floor i'm gonna like get up have a
leisurely breakfast read a book by the
pool get like some margarita get some
shrimp maybe all that stuff so
now that will be uh she enjoys the
relaxing and then i'm gonna get to see
her on the bookends of the day for a
couple days but we're there a little
early so i got a couple days to just
chill so
nice that's about all we got so this is
kind of a you know rambling show but
thank you guys um for me it was just
nice to put a pin in elden ring and
finish that so now i can like be like
all right now now i can do other things
but i had to finish that before i'm like
i start next on your list
uh tunic is probably the first one i'll
do
nice so there's tunic have a nice death
those are two that i really wanted to
get to and never got to i want to give
some space before i do horizon because
the summer is still quiet to my
knowledge of big releases on like
horizon in july or august i don't think
anything's going to be like pulling at
me because like forsaken or for spoken
um i wanted to play but that got pushed
like november or something like that so
it's going to be a while so i mean for
big single releases there's i'll horizon
will be
nice for a big summer lol i think
um yeah i've been playing rogue legacy
too
i saw that too yeah yeah people love
good quite good yeah i'm hearing good
things my boy box is playing it loving
it
nice
yeah there's there's quite a few in my
list of smaller games i wouldn't mind
getting into so
stuff that doesn't have to be a hundred
hours long when you said like eight to
ten or trek to yomi's like six i'm like
long long evening stream or something
knock it out today i'd be him down for
that
well that is about all we got ladies and
gentlemen i think we are going to wrap
up the podcast there so thank you chat
for all being around as we wrap this
thing up i know some of you guys are
taking off so thank you for everything
thank you for the show and we got a few
more weeks until
new season and then gcx is about a month
out so
for the gentleman here ty guy cognito
and myself thank you chat thank you for
all the listeners and if you made it to
the end and you're on audio or video
thank you guys for making it this far
we thank you all and for this episode it
has been